you do not want to do this trust me drop
it haven't you away
[Music]
there's no need to be frightened Isaac
look at the world what do you see
war poverty a planet on the brink of
collapse so now it's down to you and me
to put this right open
[Applause]
Tom Hardy has always been one of my
favorite actors to watch me screen is
just so interesting and each of his
roles are so unique and it brings so
much to them and I don't know I just was
captivated by him as I think most
audiences are it's not telegraphing him
next move and so it's really exciting as
a viewer because you um you're just
you're just waiting to see what happens
you never get you never lets you get
ahead
[Applause]
which sometimes can be difficult in a
movie where there are aliens and you
know mad scientists and and you have to
you have to believe that that's your
world he never compromises he just
always wants to make sure the scene as
good as it could be that we've explored
with different angles if we think about
all the different moments in every scene
in a really detailed way guys you do not
want to do this trust me he's like super
dedicated for this
whose was such a visceral performer
so concerned with everything being
honest
he's like of his generation and
brightest accurate
hey everybody we got some new venom
footage to break down and Tom Hardy
talking about Avengers crossover in a
really funny way he also refers to all
the things that they're doing in the
sonne universe as the venom verse which
I actually think is a little more
accurate than calling it the spider
verse but they do have a lot of animated
stuff going on so we'll break it down
there's a new giveaway step I'll explain
at the end of the video be sure to
subscribe to get everything
so if you weren't a huge fan of the
x-men Dark Phoenix footage from last
night
then this hopefully watch the taste out
of your mouth it'll be interesting to
see what that movie ends up looking like
compared to venom because they're both
on the bubble of the MCU right now
Marvel has just been killing it so hard
in the movie arena for so long that
people just take it for granted that
they're doing so awesome so with them
absorbing all of the x-men and Fantastic
Four characters next year it'll be
interesting to see what these other
fringe Marvel Universe movies are like
like really Sony is gonna be the only
place where you see Marvel movies that
aren't directly MCU Marvel movies
although I've already talked about how
they chose to make the movie pg-13 in
the hopes that it would make it easier
to crossover with Tom Hollands stuff but
here's that clip of Tom Hardy joking
about Avengers crossover is actually
pretty funny cuz that's where I'd love
to go with it and I'd love to go through
with the Avengers as well with him but
that's above my pay grade please maybe
you could have a world army to towards
the Avengers internally you know fire
with them the venom was to fight the
Avengers like a campaign so please will
you take us on please and if not we're
more than happy to stand alone we have a
venom version 900 characters to play I
love Riz Ahmed reacting to that would
you like me to go rig up the Avengers
and tell him you'd like to hang out have
a fight with them wouldn't you love to
see venom show up in a promo for a
Marvel movie with the Avengers the same
fight me now like when they did those
funny ads for civil war where they were
just having fun
Tom Hardy is hardcore he could probably
take a lot of those people in real life
but like they spent most of that clip of
the interviews talking about how amazing
he is in this movie I think this movie
would not have worked with another actor
I think he's probably one of the few
people that could pull this off whatever
you think about the comic book version
of the character he is totally
committed to this I posted a video from
comic-con a little while ago where he
actually talks about why he chose this
project because he's you know big enough
actor he can do pretty much anything
that he wants so it was largely his
children which is a big reason for a lot
of big Marvel actors like Cate Blanchett
would not have done thor ragnarok in the
Helicarrier had her children not big big
fans of the Marvel movies so it seems
like that's the real trick to getting
these Oscar caliber actors to do these
comic-book movies just find their kids
are you big fans of this movie please
tell your parents that they should be in
it so that we can hire them the clip of
him taking down the SWAT team is just to
let you know what it's like when he
fully becomes the character this is the
first full transformation that we've
seen on screen you've seen bits and
pieces of it and you've seen him as
venom but this is actually coming when
he's still sort of giving himself over
to the consciousness of the symbiote
when he gives them the warning it says
you don't want to do this and says well
fine okay you guys want to throw down
let's do it
he says mask and that's the cue to the
symbiote to take the driver's seat so at
this point it's still Eddie riding
shotgun and the course of the movie is
all about him finding that perfect
symbiosis balance with it so that it's
both of them working together it also
gives you a good look at how it soaks
damage it just eats those grenades for
breakfast you can kind of hurt it with
projectiles but it says that there are
certain things that are more damaging to
it than others fire in particular you
also probably spotted the funny Avengers
Easter Egg in here with them flinging
people around by his feet
venom smash
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm just a huge fan this force that is
never not gonna be funny I've seen a lot
of interesting comments from you guys on
my videos about how you think that
they're going to get to carnage an
alternate way than they did in the
comics because technically carnage was
the offspring of the Venom symbiote now
people are starting to think that they
might change that a little bit because
of the way the riot symbiote looks you
just see these red lines all over it
like the white lines of the Venom
symbiote I've already explained how they
try to change his visual style a little
bit in post-production just to
distinguish him from the Venom symbiote
when they're flying at each other on
screen so it doesn't look like this big
jumble and you can actually tell them
apart a little bit easier especially if
you're in a really dark Theater let me
know in the comments though what is your
carnage theory how do you think they get
to carnage based on the footage that
you've seen so far there's been so much
footage the last couple of days for so
many different really big things because
we're heading into New York comic-con so
I'll try to get through all those videos
as fast as possible so a couple more
trailer videos for different things
coming up leave your requests in the
comments below I'll be doing new rounds
of that spider-man ps4 giveaway in all
the Marvel videos all you have to do to
enter those just be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video real simple
click here to rewatch that x-men Dark
Phoenix trailer and click here to learn
all about Iron Man's new armor and
Avengers 4 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
guys tonight
[Music]